[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bonsoir les enfants ont soif mais oui
notre nounours a fait son marché avant
de venir comme jeanne hachette pas trop
il a acheté de la salade verte pour les
petits canards de nicolas et de
pimprenelle patron cheveux ce soir j'ai
une grande famille à foix m'asseoir au
fond le choc
hop hop hop hop hop
bon c'est vrai nounours à une famille
très nombreuse trois petits canards
trois neveux nicolas pimprenelle et tous
les petits enfants bonsoir doublons au
phare qu'est ce que tu nous as pas au
delà chalade ses portes et il n'aime pas
ça tu sais j'ai pour les petits canards
h qui vont être contents ils ont tout le
temps faim nous il n'arrête pas de
bouger comme tous ceux qui sont bien
installés c'est papa qui nous a été
et maintenant que fait la soupe spéciale
au pain des hyérois sont très gratter
ses quatre ont donné
donnez leur un peu de vertu il adore ça
petit maman regarde la bonne foi de
salades que font sans tenez regardez
tigana en coin coin
au pq leur fait peur avec ta grosse fois
un petit canard qui prenait son bain un
petit canard qui fait si coin coin ce
petit canard qui mangent études c'était
kicanas qui faisait quoi quoi petite
honor
je veux donc aux housses on me home et
belle salle un petit coq en tout on
relève que de dos et moi qui croyais
qu'ils étaient sages voalavo biberon à
l'eau a baissé à votre temps
mais qu'est ce qu'ils ont à se tenir
l'oreille comme ça pourvu que ces
paquets puces à nouveau attention
hu oui m'ennuie nonce à demain 1 2 et 3
[Musique]
cas des lumières noces panique totale
quel enfant exemple
pub
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
et voilà c'est simple tout notre petit
monde est au lit vous aussi les petits
enfants faites votre toilette embrasser
bien fort vos parents et aller vite au
dodo
un peu voilà nounours pas trop je suis
content ce sont des gens font le plein
en route vieux camarade bonne nuit des
enfants faites de beaux rêves
à demain adobe a fait 2 pour
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]